hello and welcome to this video playing
bad net maybe it's got a bad connection
okay I've lost against him once and I
don't remember what that was I always
hope to hypnotize people in jail it's
right this 7/8 it's happened it has this
happened happened to me people really
fall into the made some time that's not
the main idea of Queenie too of course
but it's an added bonus that sometimes
you get those I get those quick wins
thank 95 now as soon as I move ok not
played oh really
is it going to go to age 7 okay maybe
I'm not he's going to it so I would have
thought that it's not even possible I
can take that pawn yeah I don't see why
I shouldn't
I mean there's no discovery here the
rook is hanging on on a jade and what is
an additional issue the Queen is
attacking f7 so like Queen c7 and then
castle along is not such a simple thing
to do yeah indefinitely not Queen a5
yeah that it looks like a decent choice
so just castling short I guess
a cable should be seven he's still not
threatening to move the bishop okay I
wonder if rookie one is a good choice
threatening Oki six I mean if he castles
I take f7 just I don't see any
compensation down
yeah that's a good of covering f7
yeah Bishop f4 is the most obvious way
to answer that don't know if it's the
best dome let's do it I haven't really
looked at Queen B tour that much yeah I
couldn't couldn't believe that this
works to be honest
so look b1 Queen c2 should be 5 Pontius
rupee 7 looks absolutely terrible
he has a hard time to move anything now
bishop other M&C six queenie five is
possible the bishop cannot move this
bishop cannot move
you cannot castle I don't know that
looks bad
Knight f5 could be a threat Knight f5
pawn takes rook e5 and d7 collapses okay
so what does that do it looks at you
five
rook c7 is a very simple move against
that I don't know if it's the best
doesn't look like the best move
I still don't see anything great what
she can do them to respond castling
short he can takes his six both rooks
are hanging okay I didn't see that
beforehand
I should have seen that I really should
have anyway um so Bishop c6 let's start
with that King f8 Queen h6 check no he
allows me that movement with check and
now and now this is hanging with the
check I can just play rook see wonder or
something simple so where is the mate
[Music]
hmm don't see maid that's really hard
okay I mean everything is hanging so I
can't play that move him nothing
particularly wrong about it but I
definitely definitely missed some ways
to to end this game quicker and I only
have six seconds it's also not really
comfortable
mate in one that was helpful with five
seconds yeah I probably missed like a
million maids yeah I mean this is a
little bit odd what he did I think the
best move was probably 95 if I'm not
wrong this has been played by some
strong players like Alan the qiam you
you get this position where white is a
little bit better it's not much but why
this is a little bit better due to the
pawn structure age five I don't know I
mean he I'm better I mean where are you
going with like age five is under
pressure Knight takes F five is on the
cards
the engine is already very skeptical
yeah yeah you just material down
basically with the bad position Bishop
before was good or Bishop Bishop e3 and
then before okay I hope you want so that
was better than then my Bishop f4 even
though I mean it was fairly clear that
this should be completely winning there
was just not finding the knockout you
should be for our game
now as I said it must be a plus a
million position but group c4 was
possible okay yeah I needed Queen f7 is
made okay and Queen e5 is made yeah it's
not really a surprise seven Bishop
whatever young Brooks is seven okay this
is also winning queen is seven queen is
have wedding I got Queen to e7 that was
very obvious it's funny that the engine
finds first mates every single time like
is and such as such a problem there okay
I only had two seconds here so that was
difficult
okay guys thanks for watching